for
dear colleagues
welcome to the sakarov plenary awards
cermony in this hemicycle welcome to the
laurates we start the ceremony by
launching a
video Massa Gina's name become a symbol
of resistance of uh of demanding
Justice and recognizing suffering of
women's inside of Iran ginaa amini died
in 2022 after being arrested beaten and
tortured by Iran's morality police they
said she broke strict hijab rules with
the 2023 sacharov prize the European
Parliament honors amini and the movement
born in the wake of her death under the
rallying cry woman life
freedom
the European Parliament here's you the
world sees you and we are with you son
zendi
o
[Applause]
dear colleagues today we honor the 2023
laurates of the sakarov prize for
freedom of
thought these are Gina Mara mani and the
women life Freedom Movement of
Iran it is with regret that I must
inform you that Miss Mah Mam's family
were stopped from leaving Iran last
Saturday and are under a travel ban
imposed by the Iranian
regime that treatment is another example
of what the people of Iran face every
day let me say that the courage and
resilience of Iranian women in their
fight for justice Liberty and human
rights will not be
stopped their voices cannot be
silenced and while they are not here
today their presence will be
felt we are joined by Mr Al
nikb the armeni family lawyer who was
with us in Parliament representing them
aun naavi and Mercedes
shakar representing the women live
Freedom Movement are with us too they
have also paid a very high price for
their
fight let us also welcome the saharov
priz finalists and their representatives
here in the visitors gallery from the
United States and from nicaragu we have
Dr Colleen
mcnicholas as well as father urel valos
and missa
Enriquez representing monor Rolando Jose
Alvarez and Miss Vilma Nunes de
escorcia also like to acknowledge the
presence of Venezuelan opposition
activist Laurence s in the visitor's
Gallery Laurence was detained by the
Venezuelan authorities for his defense
of Human Rights and was in prison when
we awarded the saharov prize to the
Venezuelan opposition in 2017 and his
his presence here today is a testament
to his resilience and courage the
European Parliament thanks you all for
your unwavering dedication to protect
human rights we stand with you in
solidarity for a world where freedom and
equality are not just ideals but
realities for us
all
dear colleagues upholding the Dignity of
every individual remains a global
challenge Universal acceptance of Human
Rights is not a given but for 35 years
now the European Parliament has played a
part in defending human rights with the
saharov prize for freedom of thought the
prize recognizes individuals groups and
organizations that have made out
standing contributions in this field
many have done so at Great risk some
have paid with their lives as did Gina
mamini Gina was 22 years old she was a
daughter a sister a student a young
woman with dreams and ambition for a
better life on the 13th of September
2022 she was arrested and severely
beaten for wearing her hijab
incorrectly she died of her injuries 3
Days Later leaving behind horrible
Injustice imposed by oppressive forces
curtailing basic
freedoms but her voice was carried
around the world by women men students
academics people from all walks of life
on the streets of
Iran this was the beginning of the women
live Freedom Movement values that we
must never take for granted
since her killing hundreds more
protesters have reportedly been killed
and thousands have been
detained
aun we honor your sister hadi's memory
and we support you in your plea for
justice justice for her for you and for
the thousands in Iran fighting every day
for
dignity
Mercedes we pray raise your
determination and perseverance in your
struggle in spite of sustaining
traumatic injury and
abuse your daughter watching you now
from the gallery can be proud of you and
look towards her future with hope thanks
to
you
please know as you can see with this
room with our colleagues that your
willingness to stand up for your friends
for your family members where who were
killed or arrested Inspire us all and
your bravery in calling out abuse and
Injustice is held up as an example
across the globe please know that you
are not alone that this house is your
home and that your courage will win
because your cause is
right I give the floor now to the
representative of Miss Mam's family
Mr
honorable president of the European
Parliament honorable representatives of
uh more than 650 million uh people of
Europe ladies and
gentlemen I'm very grateful to have this
honor to be here as the representative
of massin
family today in the in this Parliament I
can read um G's mother's message which
is the a message from the whole family
this is a great honor for me
I wish um Mrs moari
herself uh or another lady could read
this message
because and the rising of Iranian people
last
year since the day xina Masa was
arrested this Rising started
by
women and women LED this
Uprising men accompanied them the result
was what you
saw and it was
ealed around the year and the slogan
of woman life Freedom that started being
uh expressed first in Kurdistan it took
all over the
world and in all over our country Iran
and over all Middle
East I read this message uh on behalf of
a grieving
[Music]
mother filled with feeling and motherly
love to her
daughter
as Mrs met said she was a
beautiful woman who had very high
Ambitions to serve
Humanity she wanted to become a medical
doctor I
am uh I should say a part of this
message is uh in
Kurdish
I hope one day we will have translators
into Kurdish as
well she is all my
heart she is my life my
blood there is no space for belief or
disbelief my existence has no reason but
her you are the scent of the essence of
spring you are the delicate fragrance of
the Rose brought by the breeze from
Blissful
Fields you are the perfume of scorched
Earth after
rain my
darling through the crap of my
darkened
window I look for the eyes of the
daughter of
light of all the songs that time murmurs
I listen to The Whisper of the tiny
Pebbles of the Pure
Source
ladies and
gentlemen I wish I could be present in
your honorable
assembly to represent all
women of my
land in expressing gratitude for the
granting of the saharov prize the ap's
token of freedom of
spirit
unfortunately we we were denied this
opportunity in violation of all legal
and human
standards our attorney Mr
nikb accompanied by Mrs
SOA will represent
us and transmit our message to
you we are
here in
France
in the birth place of Jon VAR to honor
Gina's
memory how magnificent and meaningful is
the coming together of these two
inspirational Daughters of History
across
centuries those who with their death
crossed
borders and revived the aspiration for
human emancipation and
Liberty Gina is the Incarnation of
Life her name
became a secret code for freedom and
spread the dream of Liberty from her
birthplace Kurdistan all over Iran the
Middle East and the
world
it set in motion millions of oppressed
women and human beings in the hope of a
journey towards the endless Horizon of
Salvation her life was taken
unjustly they believe that by taking her
life
they will stop her from being and
becoming in the same way as the
oppressors believe that by burning the
body of Jonah VAR they will make her
dreams disappear in
Smoke they did not know and still don't
know that From the Ashes of Joan of Ark
and Gina an unbeatable and inspirational
Spirit Will Rise Like a
Phoenix they didn't know it they still
don't
know this is the side guys
these two side Guist have now joined
each other across centuries to announce
the good news of Eternal
salvation they are the promise of
realization of elevated human
values embodied in the Progressive
slogan woman life freedom
values that rise above
borders time and
place Justice Freedom peace
coexistence and equality of all human
beings ladies Gentlemen people of the
world Gina's grief is eternal to me and
she is undying for people all over the
world I firm L believe that her name
beside that of jonar will remain as a
symbol of freedom from the birth place
of Eternal g i
convey to you my and my family's endless
gratitude and I hope that you will stand
firm and
proud by your great choice let's hope
that no voice will fear pronouncing the
word
Liberty let's hope that no voice will
fear
pronouncing
Liberty G
mother from Sak Iranian
Kurdistan
there
go
e
for
[Applause]
there colleagues we will now proceed
with the
votes
we do a quick change over thank you very
much all of
you we we start with a proposal for a
decision by the conference of presidents
setting up four delegations and defining